big and bold when i was living in france
i stayed there for three years
once twice a week i treated myself to
the most amazing
bold breakfast and it started off with
these beauties here murgays cheap but
incredibly tasty
start off with a nice hot pan mug is in
it's a very spicy sausage doesn't need
any help doesn't need any chili
just a touch
of salt and pepper
you can smell
the spice they're starting to release
all that wonderful oil that flavor in
there
add a couple of cloves i'll finely slice
garlic
spread the garlic across the pan it
instantly changes color takes on this
nice dark rich
golden colour
now take a look at the heat out with the
parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used to impart
flavor during cooking but the leaves
should always be added just before
serving to give maximum color and
fragrance
[Music]
and then finish that off with my capers
amazing
beautiful
now take your quest on
they're literally 24 hours old so
they're crispy on the outside and just
slice off
the lid
this recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
i used to cringe when i saw the french
cooks throw away croissants i used to
cry thinking oh my god
any idea what you're throwing away in
terms of flavor
whatever you do do not wipe out that pan
dunk
your croissants mopping up all that
amazing flavor and caramelizing the
inside
for that beautiful and don't forget the
lids
and then get your thumbs
and go inside the croissant
all i want to do now is just create a
little pocket
and just manipulate the quest on now
this is where it gets exciting
mix up
the capers the garlic and sausages
look at the color
of that wonderful delicious flavored
oil now some cheese
but not just any cheese fontina cheese
is like the number one cheese for
grilling and because it's a very rich
cheese you shave it thinner than you
would a white truffle but it gives a
really nice saltiness and a light smokey
flavor
a little touch of pepper
salt
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds
on the grill
here we go
nice
crisp
packs full of flavor
now top them
and that for me
it's almost like being back in paris
except this time
i don't have to share them with the
french
my ultimate big and bold breakfast
murgies and fontina stuffed croissants a
great way to start the day
that is the rib eye we've had that in
the fridge not wrapped so it sort of
almost air dries and it intensifies the
flavor gross so much quicker and there's
less water in the beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about who
washes up afterwards
so meg and i are going to avoid that by
cooking everything in one roasting tin
starting with the spinach and mushroom
stuffing
[Music]
let's do it with a salt and pepper
please
good girl
some of your left shoulder left shoulder
thank you
in with the garlic and the mushrooms to
toss the pan you push down and pull back
down and push back off you go take your
time
push it down
and flip very good that's it push down
nice that was lovely and again
nice i'm gonna drop let's see well done
well done well then right we're gonna
sort of make a little well a little
touch of butter in the middle
now we need to start putting the spinach
in the middle piece
so you can push that down spinach is
cold so you're not gonna burn yourself
be confident in the pan
toss it and you'll see it wilting
and disintegrating away wow who would
have thought all that spinach could fit
in this pan because it's a very delicate
leaf it sort of cooks so quickly put
this all on your board now
and then i just want you to go
and give that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
we need to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it
nicely good
now outside and come in gently
good
regroup
and take your time
yes mmm right
i love that smell what is that lemon
thyme lemon tan that's right so you get
your little thyme stalks and you pour
down you sort of strip
lemon thyme in now target more tastes
brilliant with the beef
fantastic with chicken and fish roughly
chop the tarragon and i sprinkle the
fresh breadcrumbs so the breadcrumbs
almost sort of bring the stuffing
together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk
now with the beef this is the exciting
part
slice
with the bone and then come inside and
go two thirds of the way down
hold that open for daddy salt
and pepper
and then look we pack our stuffing in
there
this is amazing it's incredible now just
gently hold out there like that
okay
yeah i'll see you tomorrow what
tying string around the rib will keep it
all together during roasting not too
tight if we tie it too tightly what
happens the stuffing will come out
that's right
that's ready for roasting but we're
gonna protect it and sit it on a trivet
so trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef
now a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons of mustard powder in salt
a couple of tablespoons of olive oil mix
that in
i'm gonna pour my mustard powder over
the beef so this forms a really nice
glaze
my one pot roast dinner goes into a hot
oven 15 minutes at 230 degrees then down
to 170 degrees for another two hours
for a delicious twist on traditional
yorkshire puds i'm gonna lace mine with
fresh horseradish
[Music]
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs
adding only half of your milk at this
stage makes it much easier to whisk all
the lumps out
and if like me you like your puddings a
little lighter and crispier add a
dribble of cold water and add salt to
season
when you're happy your batter is lump
free whisk in the remaining milk
peel and grate horseradish
and add a handful to the mix
we can leave the batter to rest while we
get the meat from the oven
that is beautiful and this is where you
really need to let it rest how long
would you say to rest it for um i like
to rest the meat for at least 20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
yorkshire puddings in
i love using the rich dripping but best
of all is a healthier option
to get the fluffiest yorkshires your
tray and fat must be piping hot
for best results take your jug of batter
to the oven and pour the mixture in
there
it takes just 15 minutes for our
yorkshire puds to puff themselves up and
turn a delicious golden brown lift that
up place that onto the board
parsnips parrots you can see why we kept
them in halves they've got all that
flavor one beautiful big slice
for daddy
one for maggie and then on the side it's
stuffing the stuffing a bit that's the
best to die for
now fantastic yorkshire they're amazing
aren't they beautiful mm-hmm that's been
my daddy
i met one that's for
me beautiful roast beef
with a twist
wow
[Music]
these are my odyssey river beef with
horseradish spiked yorkshire puds
am i gonna help with some pickling
please oh definitely no you love pickles
right love pickles um favorite pickle
what is it i like pickled onions we're
gonna do pickled celery mm-hmm it's a
nice little snack and great for planned
ones great for salads first thing we
need to pick the celery for me so you
see where the next one's gonna be it's
in there yeah okay i'll figure it out
but i'm hungry today is this all we're
having for dinner jack come on i
wouldn't do that too you know that
there's more coming now because we're
pickling it
we want to sort of make it look
a little bit more attractive so we go
around like that
okay on an angle
so when you pick all the food does it
does it preserve it it's exactly what it
does but also gives it a really nice
salty
soury flavour yeah okay now splash of
water and then with the sugar nice okay
so got to bring that up to the bowl
and sort of create
almost like a little syrup yeah okay
little teaspoon of peppercorns in
mustard seeds in quite generous on the
mustard seeds that gives a bit of sort
of spice now those you must know
cloves excellent cloves
in
now touch of salt no
okay
so from there white wine vinegar
now
in order for all that to actually
pickle you need to boil it
so by boiling it
okay it brings all the ingredients
together it fuses all the spices
and
helps cook the celery have a little
taste
nice nice see i put some hairs on your
chest
yes it will look boom it's working
already now see
nice
wine vinegar
right celery's ready yeah okay let's
walk to the ball now
turn that off
now
from there
start placing the celery
into that jar so when you pick other
foods can you use that same recipe
exactly that
100
once it's pickled it doesn't really go
off
okay now put them in there so can we eat
this straight away when it's in here do
you know what as soon as it's cooled
down
you can definitely eat that straight
away can't wait to dig into it at dinner
aren't they delicious yes we'll leave
that to cool down
our pickles are ready and cooling now to
marinate the chicken on the fried
chicken traditionally it's always gonna
be done with the dark meat the brown
meat so you got that nice sort of uh
drum
here and this bit
that thigh cooking on the bone as well
keeps it even more moist so first things
first salt pepper please
from there famous buttermilk buttermilk
in it's brilliant for marinating the
chicken if you can put this
buttermilk over your chicken
the night before the more it tenderizes
the chicken and starts to sort of really
relax
the chicken and puts a really nice sort
of creamy soury flavor in there so might
stick that in the fridge for us please
and we'll start the dolce de leche
biscuits
nice the argentinians call these
shortbreads alfa jorge and they're the
favorite sweet treat on the streets of
buenos aires
they're light crumbly shortbread
biscuits sandwich with gloriously golden
caramelly dolce de leche sauce
for the shortbread beat together
softened butter
granulated sugar
and beat until light and fluffy
add one egg
[Music]
slice vanilla pots
scrape out the seeds add to the mix
and beat again
[Music]
sift plain flour
corn flour
and baking powder
then fold the mixture together
using floured hands roll into small
balls
flatten into discs and place on a baking
tray
[Music]
chill for 10 minutes until firm to touch
then simply bake for 10 to 12 minutes or
until pale golden
once cooled
sandwich two biscuits together with a
camly dolce de leche sauce
[Music]
finish with a dusting of icing sugar
[Music]
delicious
my dessert and pickles are ready the
buttermilk should have worked its magic
on the chicken all that's left is to fry
it
now we're gonna roll the chicken out of
the buttermilk into the flour so that's
why it gets nice and crispy and blistery
on the outside
okay cool so what we've got to make sure
because the flour is the last coat yes
this is nicely seasoned yeah okay so
salt and pepper in there
nice
and this
is smoked paprika
so that gives it a little bit of sort of
uh
maybelline yeah yeah spice that's right
a little bit of heat and this one my
favorites what's that
cayenne pepper that's right again
slightly spicy but
the heat works brilliantly well
garlic powder traditionally are used a
lot in the steaks onion powder garlic
powder just run your fingers through
that please cool i'm gonna get the pan
on now
two centimetres
of oil this is a really good mix for
fish as well mm-hmm gushon's fighting
a nice spicy
texture
helps fish so first thing
is we just shake off some of the
buttermilk lay that down
yes okay really important to get them
covered completely okay
in the flour yeah okay
so i love fried chicken do you now
lift that up there first one and you
place it in there away from you off you
go nice and gently
good and lay away good
if any stage you think the oil is
getting too hot yeah just add a touch of
cold oil in there
or turn off the gas
good
gently fry the chicken for 25 to 30
minutes or until cooked through
now very carefully turn them over please
yeah cool
can we have this every day
jack fried chicken every day no
definitely not it's a treat and it's
shallow fried so once every three weeks
yeah sounds great to me yeah
now off with the gas
okay yeah paper ready okay
onto the paper
so then
oh nice
i love
fried chicken i'm telling you i'm pretty
sure i love it morning look here's the
best bit
delicious now
fried chicken
are pickles if you pick up um dolce de
leche cakes we are ready bud
very nice that's cool
delicious uncle mummy wow tilly phoenix
divine dolce de leche biscuits my
pickled celery and buttermilk fried
chicken a soulful street food feast if
there ever was one